he isn't thinking about winning and he
also isn't thinking about losing that's
what makes him so powerful he just wants
to enjoy himself
he's like hetero and I however I get
bored easily umber his games are
relentless unbeatable isn't he
hello welcome to Hunter hunter 101
series the breaks down everyone and
everything in the Hunter hunter world
and today we are going to attempt to
examine one of the more mysterious
sinister confusing and yet surprisingly
sparkly presences within the series with
Harriston Hill parastone Hill is a
well-groomed man of average build who is
generally seen wearing exclusively
luxurious suits in addition to this
Paris turn also sports a continuously
and relentlessly cheerful disposition to
the point where he is often accompanied
by a great array of sparkly accessories
however contrary to his friendly and
approachable appearance Barristan is a
wildly untrustworthy and unpredictable
individual who was widely disliked by
almost every person who comes into
direct contact with him although it
should be said that this is by design as
Paris to actively gain satisfaction from
the knowledge of others hating him which
you know actually might explain why he
looks so satisfied all of the time
because that's quite a lot of people as
parastone was introduced into the series
as the vice-chairman of the hunter
Association possessing official
administrative power second only to that
of netter oh and following Aceros death
power stone became the primary
antagonist of the 13th hunter chairman
election arc however before we come to
that it should be stated that power
stones rise to power was nothing less
than remarkable and due to a wide array
of factors one of which simply being his
personality
in fact met her appointed power stone as
vice-chairman simply due to the fact
that he would find power stones constant
undermining and scheming much more fun
than hiring someone of shared interests
or even worse a simple yes-man in fact
oddly enough Harriston shares that
particular personality trait with
nattara Barristan is a man who is always
on the lookout to cause the most
interesting possible scenario even ones
that are seemingly not in his best
interests and he's highly capable of
implementing said scenarios as parastone
is a natural genius and quite possibly
one of if not the most intelligent
character to have ever appeared in the
series in fact the only character who
we've really come to see rival parastone
is the legendary Jing freaks himself
however that's not quite all there is to
Barristan because although he claims to
be quite weak there are hints of
incredible power within this man some of
which are hints given out direct
Harrison himself such as when he accused
Jing of under estimating him but at the
same time almost anything Barristan says
has to be taken with a mighty grain of
salt almost an entire silo salt actually
however we do have a lot of nonverbal
evidence that there is more to mr. Hill
than meets the eye while we have no idea
what natural category of nanpara stone
falls into he is a more than capable
wielder of the art form having been
capable of engaging in a hostile use of
ren against the hunt Cheadle as well as
being completely unfazed by a show of
rain from Jing and buying a Paris tin is
capable of engaging in 10 as well it has
also been evidence that parastone is
exceptionally agile and does possess
some form of superhuman speed which was
seen during one situation where he was
fired upon by armed assailants however
the validity of this has yet to be seen
as Barristan did staged the conflict for
his own nefarious purposes so it's
highly unlikely that those bullets would
have hit him even if he stood completely
still regardless this is just scratching
the surface sir as it has been stated
the Power Stone also served as a
sparring partner for Chairman iturra and
he was able to sense Nanako aura whilst
they were healing gone something that
lower-level hunters such as a Oreo were
not able to do however I don't know if a
Oreo is a particularly high bar to clear
in terms of Nan so you know let's just
say that parastone excels at secrecy and
his combat prowess is no exception
to add to this power stones one of the
extremely rare individuals in the world
who has been granted the rank of being a
triple star hunter the criteria for
which is fulfilling the first six
articles of the hunter bylaws which
include the implication the power stone
must have mentored at least one junior
hunter who has received a star
themselves furthermore a triple star
hunter must have produced remarkable
accomplishments in multiple fields thus
making this an impossible rank to
achieve for anyone less than an
exceptional individual in fact power
stones intellectual rival and one of the
strongest and end users in the world who
has been referred to multiple times in
this video already Jing he's only a
double star hunter himself and within
the entire Association there is only
said to be around ten triple star
hunters two of which other zodiac
members auto-buy Gigante and Cheadle
Yorkshire speaking of to add another
feather to the cap that is Barristan he
was appointed to the zodiac subcommittee
of the hunter Association and assigned
the code name of rat as is expected to
this point Power Stone was heavily
disliked and even despised by each and
every one of the other zodiac members as
he would frequently use the organisation
to further his own entertainment
unlike most of the zodiac soap Ariston
did not change his appearance to mimic
his assigned animal hello could be more
accurately said that he embodies and
displays
the Bratton all of his actions because
you know the word corrupt just doesn't
quite do Paris to injustice during his
time as the vice chairman of the
Association Berenstain is suspected to
have been highly active in the
underworld and has conducted many shady
shady dealings in order to increase his
own personal power one such example was
the founding of a temporary hunter
agency hiring individuals who are not
professional hunters to conduct various
jobs for the Association however in a
situation that can only be described as
somehow the funds for the agency were
found in Paris teens personal bank
account which he claims to be a simple
misunderstanding well seems legit in
addition to this Paris tans term as
vice-chairman produced an interesting
statistic which saw a total of 18
hunters going missing during his three
years in power or on average six per
year and this is in stark contrast to
the statistic prior to his adoption of
power which saw an average of 0.6
hunters going missing per year in Paris
in himself as does somewhat confirmed
his involvement in these events stating
that if he were to become chairman then
that number would be significantly
reduced this is one of those situations
over it really is difficult to tell
whether or not paracin is being genuine
which actually applies to all situations
really but in this case he may have been
saying this to simply annoy the
individual to which he was speaking to
at the time and generate more of that
delicious hatred that he desires so much
however wielding his power as the head
of the temp agency a Zodiac and of
course vice-chairman Barristan gradually
stacked the association specifically the
review board with those loyal to him and
cultivated a great following amongst the
organization which would come into play
during the chimera an talk but he was
indirectly mentioned by Morel claiming
that she too would have been captured if
the Association had sent another
particular hunter northern speculated
that parastone was deliberately trying
to hinder the efforts of the
extermination mission which was being
organized by network in an effort to
weaken the current chairman standing
amongst the Association in this case
showing Paris tans blatant disregard for
human life as the greater the number of
victims the better it would make his
case in theory anyway but just as
predicted after the death of chairman
Metro during the extermination mission
Harriston
immediately submitted his candidacy to
become the next chairman with a swell of
support from lower ranking hunters of
the Association and began the race as by
far the favorite candidate to win now
what followed was a complex election of
Heather morphing and amending rules to
elect the next chairman
and a vicious mental battle between
Paris tan and Jing now it should be
noted that Jing was by no means a
popular candidate himself and so he
turned his attention to stopping
Berenstain using the most unlikely
accidental contender possible being lei
oreo and so after a grueling eight
rounds of voting the election would come
down to a head-to-head battle between
parastone and the Oreo and parastone was
on the verge of losing as well however
after gongs recovery the Oreo returned
to the path of becoming a doctor in
syrup Ariston hills somewhat by default
became the 13th chairman of the hunter
Association for all of two seconds that
is because as his first act he appointed
Cheadle as his vice chairman and
immediately resigned thus making Cheadle
the fourteenth chairman of the
Association now this was not an entirely
unpredictable outcome as Jing had
previously floated the idea that
Harriston had no intention of winning to
add to this Paris Tennille to chill
afterwards that he did not accept the
role of vice-chairman to one day become
the head of the Association but merely
to annoy whoever was in the chairman
role he then told Cheadle to make sure
that the Association did not fall into
boredom or else he would consider toying
with her seriously and later on
Berenstain submitted his formal
resignation from the zodiacs although
another mine in fact did arise from
around this time in that following the
conclusion of the Chimera ant
extermination mission Barristan had sent
one hundred hunter airships into East
corto and acquired the cocoons of
roughly 5000 hybrid chimera ants thus
essentially securing himself an army of
fearsome nen users now of course this
would all come to form part of a grander
plan but to examine parastone further I
am going to have to put up a spoiler
warning because the following events
have not been animated and to be honest
there's no guarantee that they ever will
be however if you are a staunch enemy
only watcher and are determined not to
have any market knowledge whatsoever
then please do skip to this time in the
video but for everyone else let us
proceed Berenstain is later revealed to
be a member of a team led by beyond
nattara son of the former chairman isaac
nattara
and is intent on traveling to the dark
continent in fact the entire reason why
Paris Tintin tour association to begin
with walls in preparation for this trip
which is deduced by Jing know at this
point intruded on the group and demanded
to be involved in the expedition
Harriston then felt something that he'd
never experienced in his life which was
hatred towards a certain individual and
to be clear Peres still is the kind of
man who enjoys hurting those whom he
loves and in this very moment he was
left pondering in a very excited manner
or for exactly what
would do to someone he hates paracin
then goes on to stage an attempt to
discover jinx and inabilities by having
them both attacked by some of the ONS
henchmen
however this by an insert failure as
well as jinx stating that parastone will
have to fight him himself in order to
discover what his true abilities are and
with this mutual understanding Harriston
temporarily decides to join forces with
Jing on their mission to the Dark
Continent
so more fun facts about Paris turn he'll
some of you may have already realized
this by now but parastone hill is
actually an anagram for a certain
celebrity who goes by the name of Paris
Hilton despite existing seemingly for
the primary purpose of hindering
chairman iturra Harriston was actually
quite fond of him noting that his
constant attempts only seemed to make
networ happier about his choice in a
vice chairman he has also been shown
expressing what appears to be genuine
regret regarding netter as death but
once again this is Paris tone so take
that as you will after resigning from
the zodiacs Paris tones position of rat
would be filled by another character who
refused to dress for the part although
it should be noted that he did bear a
striking similarity to Paris in himself
as Gorica is also a blond pretty man boy
with a slender build Harriston makes an
appearance in the 2013 film hunter
hunter the last mission however he
doesn't have any lines and all he really
does is smile and raise his hand
although he is accused of attempting to
cover up the shadow mission in the 2011
version of Hunter hunter Harriston is
voiced by Haruki Takahashi who
interestingly enough was the voice of
Hisoka
in the 1999 enemy series and finally a
truly useless fact another running gag
with power students that whenever he is
seen confronting the zodiacs it is in an
incredibly elegant chair but that pretty
much does it for parastone hill if you
enjoyed this video and the content this
channel produced in general and please
do consider donating to the new world to
view patreon because the support of all
of you amazing people is what continues
to make this channel possible and if
patreon isn't quite your style then
please do leave this video a like share
or subscribe because it also helps
support this channel an incredible
amount and if you'd like to join the fun
at any time and please do head over to
my discord server where a wide array of
shenanigan ray takes place on a daily
basis and finally please do comment with
who what or where you'd like to see
featured in the next hunter hunter
101
you
[Music]